والمزيد معنا من القاهره المتحدثه باسم
برنامج الاغذيه العالمي ريم ندى اهلا بك
سيده ريم يعني الاخبار التي تاتينا من طرف
برنامجكم
لتشيي بالخير اذا مصحه تعبير اخر
التصريحات تتحدث عن انه المساعدات بدات
تنفذ عن ماذا نتحدث
عفوا
اذا بدك تعيدي السؤال لم ابدا بالسؤال
كانت النقطه الاساسيه انه في تصريحات من
برنامج الاغذيه العالمي تتحدث ان
المساعدات بدات تنفذ وبالتالي السؤال الان
هل انتم بانتظار المزيد من المساعدات ام
تنتظرون مناشده للحصول على مساعدات
وبالتالي ايصالها للمحتاجين
هو اهم ما طلب به برنامج الاغذيه العالميه
هو فتح كل منافذ الدخول خاصه الى سوريا
للوصول الى كل الاشخاص الذين يستطيع
البرنامج مساعدتهم برنامج الاغذيه
العالميه يعمل بسوريا لذلك كان من السهل
عليه في الساعات الاولى لحدوث هذه الكارثه
الوصول الى الاشخاص بعض الاشخاص المتضررين
في حلب وفي طرطوس وفي ادلب والقرى
المجاوره وايضا في اللاذقيه ولكن لان
المساعدات كانت مستمره على مدار الايام
الماضيه ولان برنامج الاغذيه العالميه
لديه مخزون من الغذاء
لمساعده برنامج الاغذيه العالميه يوفر
حصص الغذائيه الشهريه
للخمسه ونصف المليون شخص في داخل سوريا كل
شهر لذلك كان هناك مخزون من الاغذيه ولكن
الاغذيه التي تناسب هذا الظرف وهي الحصص
الغذائيه الطارئه التي لا لا تحتاج الى
الطهي لان لا يوجد اماكن للطهي لا يوجد
بيوت اصلا لكثير من هؤلاء الاشخاص هذا هو
ما يتعين على برنامج الاغذيه العالمي
ايصاله الى كل المناطق السوريه المتضرره
متوفر ريم ليس لديكم يعني الاعتماد الكلي
الان على ما هو من المخزونات السابقه هذا
ما تقولينه
طبيعي برنامج الاغذيه العالميه يقوم بنقل
الاغذيه من تركيا ومن الداخل السوري بصفه
مستمره نظرا لان هناك
اشخاص مستفيدين من البرنامج ولكن
الغذاء المناسب لهذه الحاله يجب اعاده ملء
المخازن كان هناك كميه ما زال هناك بعض
الكميات من هذه الاغذيه الطارئه ولكن في
الايام القادمه البرنامج قد ناشط ويزال
يناشر فتح كل منافذ الدخول الى شمال سوريا
سواء المناطق التي تحت سيطره النظام او
شمال الغربي السوريه المناطق التي خارج
السيطره هل بحسب ما نفهم انه المعابر في
معظمها قد فتحت الان لايصال المساعدات هل
هناك من معرقلات بالنسبه لكم انتم او لا
الان يعتمد تعتمد المنظمات الاغاثيه على
معبر واحد فقط من تركيا الى سوريا الى
شمال سوريا
وهو معبر باب الهوى كان قبل عامين هناك
معبرين اخرين مفتوحين امام المساعدات
الانسانيه
ولكن الان هو معبر واحد فقط وهناك ضغط
كبير عليه نظرا لحجم الاحتياجات
وضروره السرعه في ادخال هذه المساعدات
بمعنى اخر القوافل بما تريدونه متواجده
على المعابر ولكنها لم تدخل حتى الان في
تكدس هذا ما تقولينه ام ماذا
حتى الان برنامج الاغذيه العالميه يعتمد
على مخزونه في داخل سوريا ولكن في الايام
القادمه سيقوم البرنامج بنقل
المساعده في الغذائيه من تركيا ومن داخل
سوريا فتبقى الايام القادمه يعني نحن نامل
في ان تفتح كل المعابر طبعا سيظل البرنامج
يستخدم معبر باب الهوى ولكن نظرا للكميه
كميه الاغذيه التي يجب توافرها ايضا هناك
احتياج للاموال فبرنامج الاغذيه العالمي
اطلق نداء للمساعدات الطارئه في
للمتضررين من هذه الكارثه في تركيا وسوريا
وهذه يعني هذان هما المطلب المطلبان او
الاحتياجات الاساسيه
لمواصله عمليات الاغاثه لبرنامج الاغذيه
العلميه للمتضررين وايضا الاشخاص الذين
يعيشون في ظروف صعبه اصلا صحيح بس حتى تتم
الاستفاده او الاستماع والاستجابه لهذه
المناشده حجم ما لديكم حتى الان للتعاطي
مع الوضع الان عندك ارقام او لا
في اي منطقه تتحدثين اتريدون ادخاله
لسوريا لان مناشدتكم هي فتح باء باقي
المعابر وايضا قضيه الاموال ولكن قلت انه
في مساعدات موجوده حجمها
المساعدات كانت حوالي تكفي المساعدات
الطارئه كانت تكفيلم 125,000 شخص في شمال
غربي سوريا الان تم توزيع
في شمال غربي سوريا مساعدات غذائيه لخمسين
الف شخص وتم توزيع مساعدات غذائيه في حلب
من الوجبات الساخنه والمساعدات الطارئه في
طرطوس واللاذقيه وحمى
حلب لحوالي
الارقام يمكن على كل
مش مشكله على كل نتمنى فتح المعابر كما
ناشدتم والحصول على باقي المساعدات من
القاهره المتحدثه باسم برنامج الاغذيه
العالمي ريم ندى شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه
المعلومات